c'est une polémique que l'on n'avait pas
vraiment vu venir
et heureusement le washington post est
là pour nous rappeler aux problématiques
les plus essentiels le quotidien
américain souhaite en l'occurrence
alerter sur ce qui est considéré comme
un paradoxe discriminatoire le titre de
l'article est le suivant la france rend
les masques obligatoire pour contrôler
le coronavirus les burqa demeure
interdite
on comprend assez vite que l'auteur
souhaite nous emmener sur le terrain
d'une possible islamophobie des
autorités françaises premier extrait
bien que la burqa a une signification
religieuse clair elle couvre aussi le
nez et la bouche et pourrait se révéler
efficace pour ralentir le virus comme
beaucoup de masques fait maison
l'article fait référence à la loi du 11
octobre 2010 interdisant le port du
voile intégral dans l'espace public en
france
un texte où il est bien précisé que
cette interdiction ne s'applique pas si
la tenue est prescrite ou autorisée par
des dispositions législatives ou
réglementaires ou bien justifiée par des
raisons de santé
un texte on ne peut plus clair donc pour
justifier le port du masque afin de
lutter contre la pandémie
mais ça ne semble pas suffisant aux yeux
de l'auteur le journaliste du washington
post donne ainsi la parole à des
intervenants français pour appuyer son
propos
c'est le cas de fatima qu'emile at
doctorante à l'institut d'études
politiques d'aix-en-provence
on voit cette lecture asymétrique du
même comportement se couvrir le visage
selon le contexte et la personne qui
agit au mieux comme arbitraire au pire
comme discriminatoire une lecture des
événements qui sert un discours
politiques bien connues car les
opposants à la loi interdisant le port
du voile intégral dans l'espace public
avait déjà fait valoir ce genre
d'arguments on retrouve notamment des
exemples de détournement de l'usagé du
masque sanitaire par des femmes
souhaitant se couvrir le visage comme
l'expliquent cet article suisse datant
de 2010 est certaine touristes orientale
choisissent ainsi de porter un masque
filtrant antipollution pour occulter la
partie inférieure de leurs visages en
lieu et place du voile intégral pour en
revenir à cet article du washington post
et comme le relève l'hebdomadaire
marianne on pourra s'étonner de la
connivence idéologique entre les
intervenants et l'auteur
visiblement peu soucieux de nuancer ou
de contredire ne serait ce qu'à minima
son analyse ce parti-pris aurait pu se
cantonner aux colonnes du journal
américain seulement
l'article a été adoubé par kinross qui
n'est autre que le directeur de l'om
j'ai international human rights watch
sur twitter en postant un lien vers
l'article en question il s'interroge
l'islamophobie peut-elle être plus
transparentes
de quoi provoquer l'indignation sur le
réseau social certains accusant le
directeur de l' ong de défense des
droits de l'homme de saper le combat de
certaines femmes
c'est le cas de karim à benounes
rapporteur spécial des nations unies
concernant les droits culturels
respectueusement
je suis déçu de ce tweet de kent roth et
washington post ils risquent de saper la
légitimité d'une mesure de santé
publique pendant une pandémie et effacer
le travail dangereux des femmes
musulmanes et les femmes de muslim
héritage
défiant la burqa on savait le port du
masque sujet à de multiples polémiques
avons que nous pensions qu'elle
porterait davantage sur son prix ou sur
la difficulté à s'en procurer
mais nos confrères outre atlantique ne
manque visiblement pas une occasion de
relancer des vieilles chimères
même en pleine pandémie